today I'm game life we talk to the
Donkey Kong dad himself Mike Micah about
how he hacked a classic game for his
daughter I did not know Donkey Kong had
a dad and it's not what I said
Donkey Kong's dad so something very
interesting happened to you recently to
make you into America's Sweetheart the
donkey called the father of America's
super Sandra Bullock totally so tell us
what happened in your own words my
daughter and I we played a lot of games
one of her favorite games is Donkey Kong
and Mario and generally I figured like
starting with those games is a great
safe way to introduce someone as young
as three games so we're playing through
Mario and we played through Donkey Kong
and then I introduced her to super my
brothers too which lets you pick from
four different characters of course and
then she immediately gravitated to
Princess Toadstool which you know fine
with me and that's yellow she would want
to play with and so they'd be fair I
gravitated towards Princess Toadstool
also but you know my favorite skill in
the game which is the ability to kind of
slowly drift down and yeah I can get
really far with this character so she
was really taken by that and always went
back to Donkey Kong she immediately
after that playing for almost a week now
and the other one she's like I want to
play as the girl and like I don't know
yeah I had to explain to her that this
is but before that other game and you
riding select the character but it kind
of stuck with me and then later that
night I I'm like I should be able to
solve this problem for her because this
is what I do five-minute games and when
she asks for something that I should be
able to do I should be able to deliver
yeah typically when a child asks a
parent to do something completely
impossible it's like you have to explain
to them like no I mean I can't go into
the game and change the graphics right
so I spent the rest of that night just
hacking at the ROM trying to figure out
how to do it and and all the challenges
that went along with that and by morning
I had a working version yeah but the
difference here probably for many other
things I've done is I kept posting to
Facebook my progress yes and so as I was
doing I would get a little response to
Bakula this is really awesome you mind
if I post it here post it there do you
mind if I tweet about it yeah and
another friend of mine he's like you
mind if I post at the ready and I'm like
sure why not yeah sure my daughter the
next morning she loved it it was really
fun
she did not know that he would stayed up
all night not reanimating the girl
character for all she knew I was like
dad finally figured it out like a
selector and so if she enjoyed that and
she died still she prefers to play that
version late that night I started my
phone just going off the hook and
hundreds of text messages people saying
like your story it's going big at this
point it was like number 16 or something
on Reddit and climbing right and it's
just that explode it touched a nerve
yeah you didn't expect it to but it is
really you know resonated with people
yeah there was like this really simple
act I just wanted to do this for my
daughter because she wanted this thing
but what I'd not realized was this is
coming on the tail end of a pretty big
thing going on online particularly the
tropes vs video games mm-hmm right I
need a Sarkisian and who was kind of
posing the question of like you know
this is just an age old thing that has
not been shattered yet really in these
games and here's how old it is necessary
thing it just showing like you know it's
the guy rescuing the garage over and
over and every Donkey Kong was like her
first real was well that was the thing I
mean it all came out of Donkey Kong but
one thing that did kind of show is this
this exposed that there is still issues
with this do you alter our masterpiece
like Donkey Kong is that right to do do
you try to placate sex's in a game or
whatever you have to have a bail and
female character in every game always
all these questions were coming up and
people were arguing and debating about
this the responses I was getting on
YouTube and actually through Gmail and
everything else like I started to get
everything from like this is amazing to
like weird like veil death threats to
there's just unbelievable they had rules
that come out of the woodwork actually
you guys helped out you helped up
particularly in the I was able to kind
of reach out to everybody through an
article through Wired in which I
explained my intentions and what I
actually did that's kind of profound to
be a I've been making games for almost
20 years this thing I did really like
turned it upside down for me and you I
mean you got some serious I mean you're
here on game life obviously but I mean
on the ladder up to this you know you
appeared on such other lesser shows as
oh I don't know Good Morning America
yeah no that was actually pretty
exciting for my parents right of course
they've been following me but it's like
oh yeah he's in those game magazines or
whatever but like my mom calling us and
they're like it's nice lady from CNN
called I think you should call her back
and they're all excited about it I
like things I do and things I can be
doing can have an effect on people and
ultimately a positive affect the amount
of positivity that came out of this and
the letters I've received from it has
been amazing
hi this is Mike mica I'm here with my
friends on game life subscribe to the
wire channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to everything subscribe to the
newspaper